well I don't have a magic prescription
for that I've never been carried away
with all we got to have everybody vote
we do that in Australia and they don't
have a better government than we have
it's the quality of those how informed
are the voters when they go to the polls
or are they just pushed in air because
of a bumper sticker that their know the
but what what it is is that you see our
system of represent is designed to
maintain the citizens in civic
adolescence what we need to do is to
cause to have mature citizens well how
do you become mature as a citizen you
take responsibility for what's going on
how can you take responsibility if you
can't make any laws directly you pass
that on to elected officials and so you
want the American people to mature and
participate truly participate give them
the power to make laws and you'll see an
unbelievable creative change in our
society the people are smarter than
their leaders it's tough for the leaders
to accept that and many times the people
don't really appreciate that but they
truly are what would you trust the vote
of the majority of 535 people in
Congress or the majority vote of the
majority of a hundred and thirty million
American citizens you'll get a better
decision by the hundred and thirty they
don't all have to vote but i'll tell you
when you have an initiative and you
failed to vote and that initiative hurts
you next time around you'll vote
yes I do because they they've been there
historically but I see nothing wrong
with adding Nevada so you get some
flavors from the West I see nothing
wrong with adding South Carolina I see
nothing wrong with moving Florida
Florida we're in a very serious change
both California and New York and Florida
have all moved up well that's going to
deflect some of the attention on these
smaller venues in the early part of
campaign but the way and I think it's
unfortunate that the Democratic
leadership has got into a bruja with
Michigan and with Florida I don't think
it's entirely fair the legislature the
Democratic elements in the legislation
in Florida made a compromise and they
had no control but they made a
compromise so that they could get paper
ballots now I hope that the entire
election in all eight is done with paper
ballots the the tragedy and literally
the criminality of these electronic
voting systems where you have no
accountability no paper trail it leaves
suspect whether or not we truly have a
fair election and we love to point to
other countries oh they don't have fair
elections I got to tell you the United
States has not seen a fair election for
some time and so the only answer I think
technology can do it but these private
companies hold their software nobody can
really examine what's going on that's
it's ridiculous that public officials
would put up with that kind but they do
and so the only safe thing to do in the
08 election have paper ballots let
people vote that way and then when we
have a government that's prepared to
bring forth the technology in a fair
fashion then we could move to electronic
voting but right now I have no
confidence that this government has the
integrity the integrity and I'm talking
about all levels of government have the
integrity
run fairly most dangerous idea for us as
a country is that we think we're better
than anybody else that's dangerous
because when you come in with that
arrogance and hubris you now start
making mistakes towards everybody else
in the world does that not characterize
our foreign policy right now and so
whether it's the East Coast liberal or
or the conservative we think we're
smarter and better than anybody else and
we're not we're not and the sooner we
can step down from our arrogant pedestal
and treat everybody as equals the sooner
we're going to have a better world our
world has the capacity and the resources
to feed everybody comfortably it's we
human beings that lack the ability the
commitment to bring about the management
of those resources so that we protect
the spaceship earth and treat everybody
fairly there's enough to go around it's
because people leaders are so bent on
power power and then it gives you the
ability to get money and that nurtures
your greed that's what we have a problem
with and that's the elites of society
first and foremost taking care of
themselves and it's and and the rest of
the people beggar thy neighbor